Today we're going to learn about a case where starting the performance of a
contract constituted acceptance.
As you already know,
it's possible to accept a contract without verbally saying I accept or signing
your name on a dotted line.
We have already encountered this when we discussed implied in fact contracts
because performance,
say a restaurant server bringing you your food is one way to show that uh,
a restaurant was agreeing to the deal more generally.
Explicit offers by default can be accepted by any reasonable means and an offer
he is.
Performance is one important way that an offeree can accept an offer
ever tight roofing corporation versus green was decided by the Court of Appeals
in Louisiana in 1955.
You might've noticed that a judge with the last name airs wrote the opinion in
case you're wondering,
he has no relation to me.
The defendant appellee green wanted someone to reroof his house and green
offered to hire the plaintiff and the appellant ever tight.
Uh,
the agreement was to become binding only upon acceptance or signature by an
officer of the plaintiff or by the plaintiffs commencement of the work.
After receiving a satisfactory credit report,
the plaintiff loaded it's truck and drove to the defendant's house to begin the
work.
To his surprise,
the plaintiff found that another company has already started doing the repair
work and the defendant told the plaintiff to go home and not to perform the
contract.
The plaintiff sued and the trial court found for the defendant,
but the instinct court reversed.
So let's begin simply in this case.
Who is the relevant offer or and who is the offeree?
Well,
the defendant green is surprisingly the offer or the plaintiff ever tight is the
offeree.
Yeah.
You might've noticed that ever tight supplied the standard form,
uh,
on which green made the offer.
Uh,
the ever tight salesmen filled out the form and green by signing it became the
offer or don't get confused by this fact.
It's possible to be the offer war,
but not the drafter of the contractual offer.
This happens whenever the offer or uses a form prepared by the offeree.
Before we get to the holding of the case,
let's take a moment to understand the terms of the offer.
Greens offer specified that it could be accepted by a home officer's signature.
Instead of empowering the salesperson to accept the offer,
this mode of acceptance gave the Home Office time to check the credit or to give
the plaintiff a chance to make sure that the price offered by the salesman for
the work was sufficiently remunerative.
Another big benefit of delaying acceptance until,
uh,
the Greens offer was brought back to the Home Office is that it avoids the
possibility that 10 salespeople will enter into conflicting contracts at the
same time.
But Greens offer again drafted by the plaintiff also stated that the offer could
be accepted by plaintiff ever tight quote commencing work on quote.
This is largely done because mistakes sometimes get made a of the procedural
kind that sometimes the Home Office officers screw up and forget to sign the
offers.
And the plaintiff wanted to be sure that it didn't ever start work on a
construction contract without a valid contract in place.
There are two major issues raised by this case.
The first is whether the defendant's offer terminated due to the passage of
time.
And the second is whether the plaintiff's action constituted sufficient
performance to accept the agreement.
Let's take a look at each of these questions.
So you'll recall from the case that the plaintiffs showed up about eight or nine
days after he heard the offer from green.
Was the offer still good by the time the plaintiff showed up?
Well,
the court held that yes,
Greens offer was still good.
It was still operative.
Uh,
when the plaintiff loaded his truck.
There are two ways to determine when an offer has terminated.
First,
the contract can specify a time.
For instance,
it can say this offer will expire in five days.
Most residential real estate offers include this kind of drop dead provision.
Second,
if no time is specified,
then the offer ends after a reasonable time.
In this case,
defendant knew that some delay would inch,
uh,
would ensue before commencement of the work and the court held that the
plaintiff's action occurred within a reasonable time.
So with regard to the first issue,
the offer was still effective at the time the plaintiff loaded it's truck
section 36 of the second restatement,
uh,
notes for different events that can terminate and offer ease,
power of acceptance,
uh,
in,
in a sense for different things that can blow up the effectiveness of an offer.
An offer is terminated if the offeree makes a counteroffer.
Uh,
the reasonable time limitation protects offerings from having their offers
hanging out there.
The offer could also revoke the offer and of course the offer expires if the
offer war of the offeree dies or becomes incapacitated.
In some ways,
the most interesting rule is that an offer is terminated if the offer makes a
counteroffer.
This also helps limit the number of outstanding offers in an negotiation in the
midst of bargaining where each side makes a series of counteroffers and an
acceptance,
uh,
then occurs.
It's a,
as a matter of accounting,
the acceptance only applies to the last offer from the other side because each
counter offer blows up all previous offers.
So let's turn to this,
uh,
to the second issue.
Did the plaintiff's action of loading it's truck with materials constitute
sufficient performance to accept the agreement?
The court held that yes,
the plaintiff did enough to accept the agreement performance began when the
trucks were loaded.
At this point,
plaintiff commenced work and this constituted a promise.
Uh,
this,
uh,
this constituted a sufficient performance to accept the offer.
As you can probably imagine,
allowing the plaintiff to accept by performance creates a lot of ambiguity.
For one thing,
it's debatable when work really starts.
Comment F to section 45 of the restatement notes that beginning per,
uh,
preparations is not enough as PR,
as perform of performance to accept an offer.
The plaintiff argues his work started when he loaded the trucks,
but the defendants argued that the work really wouldn't have begun until after
the trucks arrived at the defendant's property.
At that point,
green clearly revoked his offer by telling the plaintiff to go home and that
revocation under section 36 would have ended the plaintiff's power of
acceptance.
So you can see that timing is crucial here.
You can also imagine that the court's ruling that work began back at the office
might make it harder for the defendant off roar to know what's happening when
his offer was accepted.
The plaintiff in this case drafted the contract and can keep the defendant in
the dark by not accepting a and can commence the work without prompt.
Notice.
If a promissory acceptance by conduct commencing performance is invited,
there may be some obligation to communicate that fact,
uh,
to the offer or in a reasonable time.
So let's explore the implications of the court reasoning further.
Suppose that back at the factory ever tight loads the truck and starts driving
toward the Greens,
but on the way ever tight suddenly decides that it would prefer to go fishing.
Under the court's reasoning ever tight would be breaching the contract,
but it would be hard for green devore know this because it never found out that
the truck had ever been loaded.
It's important to note that the offer in this contract in this case could be
accepted by either promise or performance.
In this case because the offer gave ever tight the option of accepting by
promise or performance,
the beginning of performance is interpreted as a promise to complete.
Uh,
in other words,
once ever tight started performing,
once it loaded the truck,
it was making a promise to finish the project.
Uh,
you,
that's why under the earlier going fishing hypothetical,
loading the truck and then changing your mind would constitute a breach.
You can see this effect in section 62 of the restatement when offer invites an
offeree to choose between acceptance by promise and acceptance by performance.
The tender or beginning of the invited performance is an acceptance by
performance.
Okay.
On the other hand,
if the contract said that acceptance could only be by performance,
beginning performance would have only created an option contract giving ever
tight the option to dis discontinue performance without breaching a contract.
Again,
if the contract had said that ever tight,
could only perform,
could only accept by performance,
then if ever tied it changed its mind after loading the truck and uh,
decided to go fishing,
that would not have been a breach.
Section 45 makes clear for offers that can only be accepted by performance.
That beginning of performance takes away the offers,
right to revoke the offer,
but per preserves the offer he writes to reject the offer.
Roar section 45 says,
when an offer invites an offeree to accept by rendering a performance and does
not invite a promissory acceptance and option contract is created when the offer
tenders or begins the invited performance or tenders of beginning of it.
Okay.
By including the option of acceptance by performance or a signature return
promise ever tight actually wrote a contract that was friendlier to the
customer.
Then the contract had said that acceptance had to be made only by a tendering
performance.
Yeah.
So what were the damages in this case?
The answer is expectation.
For breach of a bilateral contract.
The plaintiff was awarded the,
uh,
profit lost on the job,
plus reliance expenditures,
expenses in loading the trucks.
So today we have examined a case that touched on two important issues.
First and offer expires at the time specified in the contract,
and if no time has specified,
then by default the offer expires after a reasonable amount of time has elapsed.
Second,
offers can invite acceptance by the beginning of performance to be valid
acceptance.
The performance usually has to be more than mere preparation,
but it has to be at least a beginning of performance.